BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Hello, and welcome
to this Talks at Google event.
My name is Bradley Horowitz.
I'm Vice President of
Streams, Photos, and Sharing
here at Google.
It's my pleasure to welcome
you all for this very
special afternoon together.
How many of you got to
attend yesterday's event?
Oh, good.
It looks like about half.
We had a tremendous
amount of fun.
We had four
world-class musicians
sitting up here
talking, jamming,
talking about their
craft, laughing.
I laughed.
I cried.
It was beautiful.
And more today.
Today we're going to
have a conversation
between two old friends,
Arturo Bejar Philip Glass.
And Arturo I've known
for quite a long time.
He's a bit of a Silicon
Valley institution.
And in fact, yesterday I learned
that it was Steve Wozniak who
actually brought Arturo
from Mexico to Silicon
Valley for the first time.
He later went on to found a team
called the Paranoids at Yahoo,
which was the first
of its kind, really,
in the Valley that really
focused on issues of spam
and abuse, and he
carried forward that work
to Facebook, where he
was at for many years,
building the product
infrastructure team there
and then working on
issues of compassion
and bullying and making that
a safe and comfortable place
for all of its users.
He's since moved
on from Facebook
and is now focusing on being
a father and a photographer,
and one of the subjects
of his photography
is, in fact, Philip Glass.
Philip Glass is a world
renowned composer and pianist
whose work spans generations.
He has composed over the last
25 years more than 20 operas,
8 symphonies, two
piano concertos,
and numerous
soundtracks to films
and all the while maintains
his extensive solo creations
on piano and organ.
He grew up in Baltimore,
studied at Juilliard,
moved to Europe, where he
trained with Nadia Boulanger
and closely worked with
sitar composer Ravi Shankar.
When he returned to
the States in the 60s,
he formed the Philip
Glass Ensemble
and still performs with
that group to date.
At almost 80, he's collaborated
with folks from Paul Simon
to Yo-Yo Ma and presents and
performs solo keyboard concerts
around the world.
In 2011, he founded the
Philip Glass Center,
a home for artists, scientists,
and conservationists
to collaborate and produce
a culture of renewal
for our time.
So I want to invite
these two friends up here
to have a conversation and
maybe even a bit of performance.
Philip, Arturo, welcome.
ARTURO BEJAR: Thank you.
PHILIP GLASS:
Thank you, Bradley.
Thank you.
ARTURO BEJAR: Thank you so much.
So I wanted to start,
maybe, a little bit
seeing how I ended
up here next to you.
When I was in college, the
weirdest thing I had ever heard
came on the radio.
It was "Knee Play Number 5."
And I couldn't leave there.
I needed to go to
school, and I couldn't
leave to go to school because
I had to listen to it.
And then I listened
to "Einstein"
for God knows how many times.
And fast-forward
20 something years.
And I mean, there is a little
place called Carmel Valley
that's near Carmel-by-the-Sea,
and I go into the video store,
and there's a flyer
there that says,
Philip Glass presents the
Days and Nights Festival.
And I pick it up,
and I'm like, well,
it can't be that Philip Glass.
Is there another Philip
Glass that's doing this?
And I went to the
first festival,
and I sat down to
watch this dance piece,
and right behind me,
he was sitting there.
And during the break, I
went up and said hello,
and he was very kind with
attention and conversation.
And ever since then, I have been
photographing for the festival,
and in the process
of doing that,
I have seen a collaboration
that is extraordinary
because it spans from young
people-- like, from 20 to 80--
from Africa to Japan, across
cultures, across disciplines.
And being able to be a part of
that has been an amazing gift.
And so what we'll hope
to talk about today
is a lot about that
process and collaboration.
And I wanted to start off by
asking you about your journey,
how you ended up in Big Sur.
PHILIP GLASS: I was just
thinking about that.
The festival we
have at the-- it's
the last week of September,
Big Sur this year,
at the Henry Miller Library.
It seems to be-- it was
a destination which--
I didn't know what it
was, but it became that.
When I was just beginning
writing music-- and then
shortly after that I
went study at Juilliard--
I would spend my time
practicing the piano
and working like everybody
else, and I felt so
cut off from everybody
because that's all we did.
And not just me.
Everybody did that.
And I thought, well, if
this is going to be my life,
to be this isolated, this is
not going to happen for me.
So I began
immediately-- I was 19
at the time-- I began
working with dancers
who were the same age as me.
And that's always a
good idea for anybody
who wants to know,
where do you start?
You start with people your
age, and with luck, they
stick around for a while.
And I began working with
theater companies, with dancers,
and I began
immediately-- I wanted
to get out of the
practice room, and I also
wanted to be able to perform.
And I found that dancers
always knew the music.
Theaters often needed music.
And so I didn't have
to create a concert
career at the beginning.
I just started playing
music with other people,
and that just continued.
And then the other thing
that was really interesting
was I was concerned very
much that the music that I
was doing-- I
guess you could say
it was modernistic
music of a certain kind.
But I felt that I wanted
to see, how does that
fit into the world that I live
in, into the everyday world?
And I began to think of
all of the social issues,
political issues, and by
the time I was in my 30s,
I was writing
operas about people
who changed the world
through their ideas,
like a opera about Gandhi,
an opera about Einstein.
I began using music and
theater music particularly
as a way of addressing
the issues of life,
of what we are living.
I didn't really want an abstract
music, and though in many ways
you can hear it as abstract,
music has that quality.
It always has the
quality of-- it
is emotional and abstract
at the same time.
So we'll always have that.
But I wanted to connect the
music with the power of ideas.
So I got involved
with scientists.
The other thing when I was a
kid-- so I was born in '37.
So by 1945, '46 people
began knowing who Einstein
was because of the atomic bomb.
But suddenly, this scientist
became-- he was actually
our first science superstar.
Everybody knew who Einstein was.
And what we used
to say in that time
was that everyone
knew who Einstein
was but no one understood
the theory of relativity.
They said six people in
the world understood it,
which is-- I don't think
that was an exaggeration.
Well, actually, I think there
are many more people who
know it, but that was the idea.
But I got very
interested in scientists,
and I began to see--
before I was at Juilliard,
I was at the
University of Chicago,
and I was studying
mathematics and physics,
and I wasn't
particularly good at it.
I loved it, but I
realized that I was never
going to be very good at that.
What I could do-- I
was writing music.
I knew that it was
going to be music.
I became very
interested in scientists
and environmentalists
and anybody
who was connected to the living,
organic world that we live in,
and in a funny way, I became
the scientist composer.
I've written an opera about
Einstein, Galileo, Kepler,
Stephen Hawking.
I did a movie about him.
Just a couple years ago, Brian
Greene, who is a string theory
physicist-- I did
a piece with him.
So I began writing
music for sciences.
And then, in fact, this
year, one of the people
who's going to come at the--
the center is about music.
It's about dance.
It's about film.
It's about poetry.
All those things are in
this festival this year.
But I have these
other issues, too.
So someone I know has
written a book called
"The Well-Tempered City,"
and it's about-- his name
was Jonathan Rose.
He does a very interesting
study of cities from Ur.
We call that the first city.
He compares it to
Baltimore and Dayton,
and he talks about
the issues of what
a city needs to do to be
successful or to survive.
You know, there are cities
around the world that
have suddenly disappeared,
and we don't know why.
They become ghost towns.
We think maybe the water
supply disappeared,
or there was a
disease or something.
But you can visit these cities.
So there are cities that
have been successful.
Paris, London-- they've
been around a long time.
We don't know what San
Francisco or Los Angeles-- I
don't know if they've been
around that long yet, but any
of the New World cities--
well, Mexico City.
My god, that's an amazing city.
When Cortes arrived and they
saw Mexico City, at that time
it was in the Valley of Mexico.
You know this-- because
he's from Mexico.
There were a million
people living there.
Now at that time, we're
talking about the 15th century.
The European cities
were 30,000, 40,000.
London was 40, 50,000.
Mexico City was
a million people.
Now they had already
mastered some-- of course,
you know all this.
It was a city that
was built on water,
and so there were-- and
it's all very interesting.
But I got interested
in all this stuff.
And so this year,
Johnson Rose is
going to be giving talks
about the well-tempered city.
And he uses the well-tempered--
from the Bach idea,
the well-tempered clavier.
It has to do about
tuning, and it's
a subtle and
extremely intriguing
idea about perfect tuning,
about relative tuning.
Actually, this is
relative tuning.
And besides that, Jonathan
also plays electric bass,
which you know, and he's going
to be playing electric bass one
night of the concert.
So I've got my
scientist playing bass
in the orchestra, which is--
so these kinds of things that
interest me, where you
have a meeting of cultures.
And here's the interesting
thing, I think.
That people that are
interested in science
are very often interested
in music and in dance.
It's the same people.
And the other thing
that I began to realize
is the more I knew
about science,
I began to think of science
as a kind of poetry.
ARTURO BEJAR:
Yeah, and so that's
one of the things I
wanted to ask you about--
was to talk a little bit
about the piece for Brian
Greene around the black holes.
Like, you take a concept
around physics concepts.
And how do you match
those to musical language?
PHILIP GLASS: Well, now I did
the black hole-- of course,
everybody knows this.
I'll tell you anyway.
If you get too near a black
hole, you get sucked into it,
and you can't get out.
But it has other
property of-- time
slows down so that when you
get into the black hole,
time is actually stopped.
So when I was writing
this piece with-- Brian
would call me and say,
have you got to the part
where the time slows down?
I said, yeah, I'm
working on it now.
He said, can I come
down and hear it?
I said OK.
So he came down to the studio,
and I played this piece
where the music was very
high and moving very fast,
and as it goes lower and lower,
it gets slower and slower,
and finally, it just stops.
And Brian said, yeah, that's it.
And he said, you know, I
insist that this is accurate.
Again, I was turning science
into poetry, actually.
But now getting back to
this idea about poetry--
and I'm very serious
about this-- Einstein was
asked-- once he was describing
where he got his ideas.
A lot of times it would
be the idea of relativity.
He said, well-- this
is what he said.
I imagine myself sitting
on a beam of light,
and the beam of light is
rushing through the universe
at the speed of light.
And I look around me, I saw
everything rushing past me,
and I was standing still.
He said, after that, it was
just a question of figuring out
the mathematics, which
he said was hard for him.
What?
Evidently, it was not hard--
I mean, not that hard for him.
But so I began to
see-- not only him,
but you look at
someone like Darwin.
The biological sciences
are very different
from the physical sciences.
The physical
sciences-- we do a lot
of deduction and mathematics.
Biological science--
there's induction.
That means a lot of observation.
He went on the famous
voyage of the Beagle.
He was, I think, out for about
two years in a boat and just
looking at species and how
they change from island--
he was out in the south
seas, and he went from island
to island.
He would see that
almost the same species
would be on another island
but had changed a little bit.
He began to see how
biological entities like this
could change, and he didn't
think very much about it.
He just collected information,
collected information.
And he finally came up with this
astonishing idea of mutation,
that things change because
of sunspots or whatever
for natural reasons,
and then what
he called natural
selection, which
is that after the
mutation change,
this new entity, if
it has survivability,
would then replace
the non-mutated one so
that natural selection
became a form-- that's
where the idea of
evolution came from.
And this is also
an astonishing--
if you think about it.
I mean, can you imagine
if you had been doing this
and you had been on
a boat for two years
just looking at flowers?
Would you have come
up with this idea?
ARTURO BEJAR: I don't think so.
PHILIP GLASS: I don't
know about that.
I just find that these
amazing scientists
have the dreams of poets.
And then they have to find
the science to explain it.
But without the vision,
there is no theory.
So in a way, I began to see--
I came to this as a very
young man, and I
began to see science
as a form of poetry, a
poetry which has the ability
to create technology
which then really changes
things even more rapidly.
So I got very involved with
the idea of science in music,
and then of course, because
as a modern person--
I began to think about climate
change and things like that.
And so the concerts that we
do and what I try to do-- I'm
trying to bring
them all together,
and we are actually
kind of succeeding.
And this time, Jonathan
is going to come and give
a talk about the city.
I've got the copy
of the final draft.
It's not been printed yet.
It's so interesting to read.
It is kind of like
poetry, but it
took someone who was willing to
sit down and think about this
and to come up with
the-- you know Jonathan.
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah.
PHILIP GLASS: At any rate-- so
anyway, what was the question?
ARTURO BEJAR: No,
you talked about it.
It was about how you set black
holes to music or the theory
behind it to music.
PHILIP GLASS: You
know, what I find
is that it's not just my ideas.
I find many people are
interested in science
and art and dance and theater.
Poetry.
It goes together very well.
ARTURO BEJAR: Which
takes me to another thing
that I got to watch, which was
the concept around language
and collaboration.
So I was wondering
if you could talk
a little bit about
when you began
collaborating with Foday Suso.
PHILIP GLASS: Oh,
that's interesting.
That's a different thing.
I was cooperating with
dancers and filmmakers
at the center over
there, and then I
began collaborating with
composers, first just people
that I knew-- but then I
began working with composers
from completely
different traditions,
and that really changed my ideas
about music more than anything
else.
I just played Arturo
some music that I
had made with some indigenous
people from Mexico.
Indians, actually, who
live in the mountains.
They didn't even speak Spanish.
I certainly didn't
speak Indian languages.
And we managed to put
a record together.
And with Foday
Suso-- he's a griot.
He's from the Mandinka people
in West Africa, the Gambia.
That's near Senegal and Mali,
kind of right in between them.
And he tells a story of the
Mandinka people and music.
The griots do that.
They have something
like 107, 106 songs
that they have to learn.
I know him very well.
I met him more
than 35 years ago.
We do concerts quite a
lot together since then.
But let me tell you a
story, a funny story.
Then maybe we will go
on to something else
because I can tell funny stories
all night without getting
to the point that we're maybe
trying to get to, which--
I'm not even sure what it is.
So the first time
I saw Foday, he
has a big kora, which is a
gourd, and there are 17--
or is it-- 17, 18 strings.
And he plays the strings.
It's like a harp.
And the gourd takes the sound,
and it comes out that way.
Of course, we also
amplify it, too.
I was asked to do
music for a play
by Jean Genet called "Les
Paravents," "The Screens."
Now, it was a story about
the French in North Africa.
So I thought, well,
maybe I should
do a piece with an
African composer,
and I would be the
European-based-- I'm not
European, but the music is based
on Central European art music,
so that goes with that.
And so I asked Foday-- I
had gone on a trip with him
to Africa working with Godfrey
Reggio in a movie called
"Powaqqatsi," and he had
taken me to hear music,
but I hadn't thought that
much about the music itself.
I mean, I liked it,
but I didn't really
think about how it was made.
And so then I called Foday.
I said, I have to do this piece.
We have to do African
and European music
sometimes together but
sometimes separate.
OK.
So we came to the studio.
And now I knew this
from my experiences--
the first thing we had to do
was to tune the instruments.
I mean, without that,
we can't even play.
This is basic stuff.
The piano was a little
too complicated.
So we kept the piano, and
he would tune to the piano.
Now, the scale in
the African music
is a little bit different.
The fourth-- I don't know.
So not to get too technical,
but the fourth note of the scale
is a little more
flat than ours is,
and the third is a
little more sharp.
So if you listen to-- if
he played with the piano,
somebody would
sound out of tune.
It probably would have been
him because I can play louder
than him, but not necessarily.
So he had lived in the
States for a while.
He traveled back
and forth to Africa,
but he came, and he
had learned to retune.
He was retuning his instrument.
He was playing with Herbie
Hancock and people like that
and playing at jazz, and
he had to tune with them,
so he knew how to do it.
I didn't know
anything about that.
So we sat down, and he played a
note which was similar to an A,
very close to an A, and he
said, this is the first note.
I said, OK, so here's the
A. Here's my piano note.
And he tuned it, got it right,
and he nodded and said--
and I go to the B
flat above that,
and he played-- well, actually,
I went to the B natural
because we were kind of in D.
And he played the B, and
I said, wait a second.
What do you call the first note?
He said, well, that's
the first note.
I said OK, did the
second note, and I said,
what do you call this?
And he said, I call
that the second note.
And then we got to the third
note, which is C sharp.
I tuned it, and he said--
I knew what was coming.
And he said, that's the
one that's the one that
comes after the one before.
And then I suddenly
had the realization
that his notes
didn't have names.
And when I was a kid, I
took my first flute lesson
with a flutist from the Peabody
Conservatory in Baltimore.
And he gave me a flute.
You hold it like this.
He said, OK, put your thumb
here and the finger there.
And I had the position, and
I blow through the hole here.
And he's pointing on the page.
He said, that's
a B. He showed me
what it looked like, he
showed what it sounded like,
and he showed me
how to finger it.
So at that moment, I identified
the name of the note,
the position of the hand, and
the intonation of the note.
There was the sound of the
note, the key of the note.
This was now-- oh, I would guess
25 years later, 20 years later.
I'm sitting with this
guy, and he tells me there
are no names to the notes.
And I almost fainted.
I was so shocked.
I felt like the
floor had opened up
and I was floating in the air.
I said, Foday, I have to stop.
And I got up, and I had to
walk out and walked around.
I said this is-- I
couldn't fathom this,
that he could play music without
knowing the names of the notes.
So we got over that.
We ended up being
collaborators, and we've
done many, many
concerts together.
He knows the names of the
notes now, by the way.
But he never bothered to
know them before that.
So when I began working with
people from other traditions,
the way we understand
music not emotionally
but structurally
and intellectually--
it was very different.
Emotionally, I could
understand it very quickly,
but how he thought
about it I didn't.
This happened some years before.
It happened when I had been
working with Ravi Shankar
and I was working
with Alla Rahka.
I was learning the rhythmic
system of Indian music.
That's the end of the story.
I won't get into it.
Anyway, that was
another good story which
I'm not going to tell now.
But the point was that I
began to see that in order
for musicians to
play together who
come from-- we have to start
to make some accommodation.
And when he went back
to Africa, by the way,
and his friends found out he
had retuned the instruments,
they were very upset.
They said, you can't
retune the kora.
He said, well, if you want
to play in Europe or America,
you've got to retune.
And they said, no, no, no.
We're not going to retune.
He said, well, then you're
not going to play out.
You're not going to play there.
And so he said, well,
let me hear you play.
And then he had
retuned the kora,
and he was playing the kora.
And he said, it sounded perfect.
Same thing happened
Ravi Shankar.
When he came to
America and Europe
in person to some big
concerts, back in India
they thought he had
betrayed the raga,
and he had to go back to India
and do it at a big concert.
He told me this.
He did a big concert in
Bombay and one in Delhi,
and he had to prove to people
he could still play the sitar.
They thought he had
forgotten how to play it.
ARTURO BEJAR: Wow.
PHILIP GLASS: So the
tuning thing is a big deal.
But what was
interesting was I began
to understand that there's
a relative truth to music,
and there's an absolute truth.
The absolute truth we
have no problem with.
It's the relative truth
that we have the problem
with, the tuning.
But when I don't have
to do the tuning,
I can totally get-- working
with the Mexican musicians,
I could not figure
out how they counted.
They were doing it
in a rhythmic cycle,
but it sounded to me like
there would be a cycle of 15,
then a cycle of
15, a cycle of 15.
Then it'd be cycle of 14.
And I counted again, and every
third time it would be 14.
I said, OK, I got it.
And then the next time
they did it, it was 16.
I couldn't figure--
well, how do they--
do they just remember that?
And were they counting at all?
I think they weren't counting.
And I was playing
with this one guy.
He was playing the--
we called it a guitar.
It looks like a guitar,
but he built it himself.
We had someone translating
into Spanish for me.
And I was playing
with him a while,
and I was trying just to play
with him, and after a while,
he said, you got it.
You got it.
And I began playing with
them, and I missed it again.
I never figured
out how to do it,
but what I figured
out-- another thing.
A different thing.
I found out, if I
played in a cycle
long enough, that the
inconsistencies didn't matter.
Everything would add up to
maybe 86 or something like that.
I had to work in
a very big cycle,
and then we could be together.
ARTURO BEJAR: And that
takes me to the-- he's
going to play a little bit,
but there's one more question
before we play for a little bit
and come back to talking later,
which is-- so you
take these rooms that
have Jaron Lanier,
Jonathan Rose,
the guy that comes from
a technology background.
You've got Suso.
You've got all of
these people from
different artistic
sensibilities, instruments,
musical language.
They're all talented,
strong-minded.
How do you get--
PHILIP GLASS: Well, at the
beginning, in the early 60s,
we used to get
together, and we'd have
what we called a world band.
And you'd find
someone from Africa.
You'd get someone from India.
And you all get together,
and it sounded terrible
because everybody was
in a different key--
slightly different.
It's not that you were
in a different key,
but the fourths were different,
the thirds were different,
the sixths were different
so that someone was always
out of tune, and we never
sat down and retuned.
Basically, these world
bands just dissolved,
and then after a while,
no one did it anymore.
It didn't start up again until
I began playing with people,
and we actually addressed
the issue of tuning.
That's why it was so-- since
we were in North America,
we used the European tuning.
Now there are certain
instruments you can't use.
A Balaton, which is like a
xylophone-- you can't return
it, so you won't find that
instrument in any of the-- you
won't find the African
balafon, but you'll
find in my music an
American xylophone.
I have to pick one that's--
some things you can't tune.
In Australia, the
didgeridoo player--
you know what a didgeridoo is?
A long-- I had
one guy I played--
I love this guy, Mark Atkins.
And I said, Mark, how do
you make-- where did you
get that instrument?
He said, well, I get
a limb off a tree,
and then I put the ants in,
and the ants eat their way
through the center.
He said, I have to come back in
about maybe four, five weeks,
and then knock it out, and
all the inside of it goes out,
and I have a long tube.
And he said, and
that's what I play.
And I had this fantastic
conversation, and I said, OK.
Now I was playing with him, and
I said, how do you play that?
What are you thinking about
when you're playing it?
He said, well-- and we're
doing a piece called "Orion."
I did it with musicians
from Brazil, from Africa,
from China.
I had five or six--
a guy, Ashton McIsaac
from Cape Breton,
who played violin.
And so I began asking people
where their music came from.
This was the most
interesting thing.
I said, where does
the music come from?
It's a very simple question.
And most said,
oh, I'll tell you.
I get to this place in the
music, and I close my eyes
and I see a kangaroo
running across the outback,
and I play the music
that goes with him.
I asked Ravi Shankar.
I ask everybody.
I ask everybody this question.
You get the most-- it's
a very simple question,
and if you ask it not
knowing what the answer is,
you'll get the answer.
They'll tell you
what they think.
I asked Ravi Shankar once.
I said, Ravi, where does
this music come from?
I was sitting with him in
his hotel room in London.
It was years and years ago.
And he turned-- this
is a great story.
He was sitting on the
bed crossed legged,
and I was sitting in a
chair, and on the table
was a picture of
an Indian gentleman
in a narrow kind of coat.
He turned to the picture, and
he did a full prostration,
bowed to the
picture, and he said,
the grace of the guru,
the music is coming to me.
That beautiful?
Now let me tell you one more
because you'll like this one.
This is from the
Indian Mexican guy.
I like to tell Mexican stories.
So we had done a
concert together.
We had just done
a concert together
in a little place called Real
de Catorce with these two
musicians, and there was one
guy who was our translator.
And we went on afterwards
to have a nice fire.
And they like to do that.
Nice big fire outside.
Concert was over.
We all went out to do the fire.
[INAUDIBLE] was standing there,
and I say, [INAUDIBLE], where
does that music come from?
The same question.
You'll never-- you can't
imagine what people say.
Unimaginable things.
He said, well, I
looked at my father--
my grandfather, the fire.
My grandfather, the
fire, has no mouth,
so when he wants to
sing, he has to use mine.
ARTURO BEJAR: Oh, wow.
PHILIP GLASS: I mean, these are
revelations that are profound,
and I must say that I've
gone through my life in music
talking to people very
simply about music
and asking what-- and then
people ask me the same thing.
I say-- I had even
better-- I don't
know if I'll go into that.
Shall we go onto something else?
ARTURO BEJAR: Yes.
The piano, and then I'll ask
you where that music came from.
PHILIP GLASS: Oh, OK.
OK.
I said I was going to play.
We had a wonderful
concert yesterday,
and I thought I couldn't come
here and not play tonight.
So it's going to be one
piece called "Mad Rush."
I'm playing it because
he likes that piece.
I hope you like it, too.
It's a piece originally written
for the organ of St. John
the Divine, the
cathedral in New York.
It was the occasion of the
Dalai Lama's first visit
to New York in '78, and they
were going to give a talk.
And the people who organized
the event weren't sure
when he was going to arrive
exactly, so they said, well,
why don't you-- could you play,
just play some music until he
comes?
Oh, I didn't know when he
was going to come, either.
So I had composed-- I
composed the music for that,
and that occasion, I
played for about half an--
I'm not gong to play
for half an hour.
I'll play about 14 minutes.
So I made a piece of
indefinite length.
Actually, not a problem.
On that occasion,
it was half an hour,
but I'm going to play about
half that version right now.
So this is-- oh, the piece
is called "Mad Rush."
[APPLAUSE]
[PLAYING "MAD RUSH"]
Thank you.
ARTURO BEJAR: I love you, man.
PHILIP GLASS: What was that?
So where did that come from?
PHILIP GLASS: You know, I
ask myself the same question.
I could never come up
with the right answer.
But something-- I come up
with an answer for a while.
I first say, well, music
is a kind of language.
But you know, that's
like saying a chicken is
kind of like a bird.
It doesn't tell you anything.
It doesn't tell you something
you already don't know.
It didn't reveal anything to
me, and I was very dissatisfied
with that, but for a long
while, I had no answer.
So I would continue
asking people.
And then about four
or five years ago,
I was giving a talk, kind of
like we're doing right now,
and someone in the
audience said, well,
where does music come from?
And here's what I did.
I answered.
I said something I
wasn't prepared to say.
It was almost like
someone else had said it.
I said, well, music is a place.
It's as real as Chicago
or Atlanta or Boston.
It's a place, and when
you go to listen to music,
you go to that place.
I thought, OK.
I hadn't heard that
one before, and I
thought that was--
that seems right to me.
ARTURO BEJAR: So
one of the things
that I appreciate the
most about your career
is that you have
these collaborations,
like with Godfrey--
began with "Powaqqatsi,"
and made a movie a couple of
years ago, a year or two ago.
You have Suso.
You have the ensemble
that's been together
for a really long time.
And so how you
manage to have all
of these great
collaborative friendships
over that long a period of
time and have them sustained?
PHILIP GLASS: You
know, I'm-- music is,
above everything else,
a social activity.
It's not only between
myself and the audience.
It's between the
people that play.
I accepted that very early.
As a boy, I played a
flute in an orchestra.
I was 10 years old.
I was playing in
the orchestra then.
Music to me was always something
that people did together.
It wasn't a problem.
I've met now--
because of the-- I've
met several players, musicians
here, on this trip here,
and I'm going to be playing
with them at some point.
As soon as I hear somebody or
I meet them, if I like them,
I want to play music with them,
and then I find a way to do it.
Then I have to look and say, do
I really have time to do this?
And I look, and it goes,
yeah, there is a state.
And I find it, and I
just put the date in.
Yeah.
It's like I kind of, I would
say-- not an obsession,
because it has a
negative sound to it.
It's an attraction that
is very strong for me.
And so all playing with other
people-- I do do concerts.
I do solo concerts, and I like
to do them in a certain way
because when I do solo
concerts, I can often
play pieces differently.
If I play with other people,
then I have to play the way
I wrote it.
Well, that's pretty
much the way I wrote it.
But I'd like to do
solo concerts also
because that's
something different.
It is not so much about
playing with another person
but playing in front of people.
Now this is the most
interesting thing.
Music is a transaction between--
that's what we say in language.
But it's something
that passes between us.
You know, they found-- I
read this a year or so ago.
They found in some caves--
these caves are always
in France for some reason.
They found-- they think
it's an instrument.
They found wings of a pigeon
that were hollowed out,
and they just thought
that these were
very early versions of flute.
70,000 years ago.
You know, I think that
was the first language.
Maybe people picked it
up, and they made a song.
Do you go to-- you
know, I also never miss
going to one of these
natural history museums
and going-- I find
them extremely--
not only to hear, to see what
contemporary people are like
but to go back in time.
That's why I really-- Jonathan
spoke about the first city, Ur.
So interesting for me.
The thing is that our
humanness, the thing that
makes us distinct from--
it seems unique, in a way.
Of course, it's probably
maybe not unique,
but it strikes us that way.
It's not just our attachment.
Even our-- what is the
opposite of attachment?
We're repelled by certain
activities, certain people.
Whatever it is, whether
we're attracted to it
or repelled by it,
it's so strong.
You know, this is an
interesting thing.
We talk about the
art of ancient times,
and we look at-- we can
see the vases from Egypt
or the pyramids in
Mexico or the clothing
they find that's left over
from some nomadic people living
in Siberia or
someplace like that.
Everything-- I find that
extremely interesting
and deeply moving,
and I'm not sure why,
because I don't need
to read about it.
I just need to be in
the presence of it.
So in a way, you
say, how do I do it?
I'm drawn to do it.
It's my nature to play music,
and I've played it all my life.
And if I meet someone, if I
have any connection to them
at all-- they can play music?
I'll play music with them,
because something happens.
Isn't that so?
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah.
I've seen that.
And so coming back to
the festival, what would
be your vision or your hope?
PHILIP GLASS: My what?
ARTURO BEJAR: Vision
or hope around the--
PHILIP GLASS: I would like--
we're building the festival up.
This year, Victor Sanchez
has come from Mexico.
He works in the field of what
we call human development,
human behavior.
He has amazing
things that he does.
He takes people into the
desert or-- and there, we're
going to go into a number of
national forests in the area.
Pfeiffer Forest is right
there down there in Big Sur.
And he goes into-- he goes
in with 10, 20, sometimes
30 people, and they
can go for a week.
I think what we're going
to do there-- he'll
work in the daytime
with a group of people.
And these are actually
transforming experiences
because he's spent
his life doing this.
And he's found out
things in nature
which you have no
idea what they are.
I've seen them, because
I've been with him.
So his coming, he'll
be in the daytime.
Then we have the
concerts at night.
And it will be, or
they'll be-- in this case,
we have a movie of Laurie
Anderson called-- her dog
movie, wonderful movie.
And she just made it.
And then the second night,
I'm doing an evening
of poetry and music with her.
Then we have the
Club Diamond, which
is a small but very
intense and beautiful
theater piece for one
performer and a musician,
and based on the activity
of street performers
in Tokyo who go around
and entertain children,
and they give them candy, and
they-- they just go from place
to place and do that.
And this character is the
character of this piece.
You have to see it.
It's really beautiful.
We're going to have
some music before then,
but I'm going to get some
music, some younger composers.
Then the next night, we have
this piece by Jerry Quickley.
It's called "The Whistleblower."
It's about--
ARTURO BEJAR: Edward Snowden--
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah.
ARTURO BEJAR: --and the
surveillance state and--
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah,
the whole thing.
And it's wildly
funny and touching.
And it's mixed in with
parts about Allen Ginsberg.
And now how he did
that, I don't know.
But he's got Allen in there too.
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah, I'll
expand on that a little bit.
The Allen Ginsberg
piece is written
from the perspective
of the agent that
is signed to surveil him.
And it's derived from
the papers that they
got published about this agent
that was surveilling Ginsberg.
And it's amazing.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah,
he got the papers
from the Freedom
of Information Act.
He got these papers.
And it becomes the thing.
And so we have that one.
So then we'll have some-- and
then Foday Suso will playing.
I'll be in front.
We'll be doing a musical.
We'll be doing-- I think that's
one where I think that our bass
player will be playing with.
That's with a string
quartet with Jerry Quickley.
But I think it will just
be Foday and myself.
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah.
PHILIP GLASS: So it's-- with
a very few handful of people,
we cover a huge, a very
big area of activity.
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah.
And so, like, if the
festival sounds really cool--
and I wanted-- if you have
any questions that you want
to ask him, part of the
goal of coming here today
is feel free to
ask him anything.
We still have some
time, and I wanted
to allow enough time for that.
But if the idea of the festival
sounds like really interesting
to you and you want to
be involved or engaged
in some way, just grab
me when we're done here.
PHILIP GLASS: You have
some information, yeah.
ARTURO BEJAR: And we
can take it from there.
Because I think
it's extraordinary
that-- like you were
anywhere else in the world,
you would go to New York.
And you would perform at
Carnegie Hall, or the Met,
and you'd come out, do your
thing, and then you'd be out.
And they'll be waving
from the audience,
but it would be about it.
And here there's an opportunity
to be with 100, 200 people,
and--
PHILIP GLASS: Maybe 300 of them.
We're at the Henry
Miller Library,
which is an outdoor
venue in the Redwoods.
And it's just very intimate.
And it probably
could be 300 people.
He is-- it's legal now for
him to do these concerts.
But he had to get
some kind of permit
through the state or something.
And they're allowing
him 300 people.
ARTURO BEJAR: OK.
So does anybody
have any questions
that they would
like to ask Phil?
And please, come up
to the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hi, how are you?
Actually, first
question would be,
when is the Henry Miller show?
ARTURO BEJAR: The Henry
Miller Memorial Library--
AUDIENCE: Ah.
ARTURO BEJAR: --last
weekend of September.
PHILIP GLASS: It's in Big Sur.
ARTURO BEJAR: In Big Sur.
AUDIENCE: Last
weekend-- OK, great.
I had a question.
I play music most of my life.
And it's great to see
someone with such a library
and done so much.
And one thing I've
seen, including myself,
is a lot of people who play
music do it out of passion.
And then they lose that passion,
or they become uninspired.
And you spoke a little
earlier about, like,
someone being inspired is
as simple as a imagining
a kangaroo running.
And I was just wondering,
what is your inspiration,
or how do you continue to find
inspiration in writing music
throughout your entire life?
PHILIP GLASS: I didn't
completely hear.
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah, so how
do find and keep inspiration
throughout your life?
What feeds your creative--
PHILIP GLASS: Oh, it's my
insane, intense curiosity
really.
I find it all so interesting.
I have no trouble-- I
have trouble sleeping
in the morning.
I get up early and start
thinking about this stuff.
Right now, I'm
working on the music
for Jerry's piece,
which we're going to be
starting to rehearse in May.
So I get up for that.
And then I'm working on a new
symphony later in the day.
I don't know.
I find it very interesting.
And right now,
there's a movement
in the world of performance
and music of younger people,
people in their 20s
and early 30s, that's
extremely interesting.
And it's happening--
this happened--
OK, I can tell you that
many of you don't know this.
But 60 year ago, when the
McCarthy communist trials
were going on, at that time,
it was a terrible time.
It was even as-- it
was as bad as Trump.
It was really that bad.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, Trump-- McCarthy
was a real-- anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
And at that time,
what happened--
you had Allen Ginsberg
coming around then.
And then you had
William Burroughs.
And you had all this-- there was
a sudden explosion of the art,
of creativity.
And I began to think, that's
mother nature balancing it.
You know, you get
some insanity here.
Then you have to have some art
over here to make it bearable.
I really believe that's true.
Now we're in the-- I
don't have to tell you.
The news, you can
barely watch it.
It's gotten horrific.
It's terrible.
And yet at the same
time, I find young people
as more idealistic and
committed to self-expression
and exploration
of their humanity
than I have seen
in 30 or 40 years.
It's very, very-- if you--
it's a very, very rich time
right now for poets, for
musicians, for artists.
So if you get tired of watching
this junk on television,
go out and see
some of the stuff.
It's really-- I'm sure
that you can find it.
It's all over the place.
AUDIENCE: I try to fill my life
with that on a daily basis.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
About five years
ago, a friend of mine
said that she had
just released an album
of her own compositions.
And I said, oh, that's nice.
I've never been able
to compose music.
And she said, your
best friend just died.
Go over to the piano
and play something.
OK.
And I went over and started
at A minor and something.
And then it kind of
worked into another key.
And then it finished.
And I-- I never experienced
anything like that.
And since then-- then
my first thought is,
well, is this really music?
You know, because I did it.
But it was, you know, now--
PHILIP GLASS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --I can
play some things.
PHILIP GLASS: By the way,
you're the piano tuner right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PHILIP GLASS: This is the
guy that tuned the piano.
[APPLAUSE]
And he told me just
before the concert,
he said, yeah, I've been
tuning the piano all my life.
And I've just started
to write music now.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PHILIP GLASS: So maybe he'll--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PHILIP GLASS: Thank
you for your thoughts.
AUDIENCE: Well, first I want
to thank you for being here.
You've been sort of one of the
gods of my musical pantheon
since I first saw [INAUDIBLE]
back in the early '80s
when it first came out.
I wanted to know if
you thought about
or if you've talked
about how the internet
and the communication
technology we have now and sort
of the democratizing
out elements of that
are part of that explosion of
creativity and self-expression
you had just mentioned.
PHILIP GLASS: I
didn't quite hear.
ARTURO BEJAR: So how
does the-- how do
you think the internet has
democratized and opened up
creativity?
PHILIP GLASS: It's
helped me a lot.
I was writing music
for a play recently.
I was in the theater.
And the director said, I need
a song for the end of the play.
So I-- I was watching--
I wrote the song.
And I took a picture of it was
my camera, my little, you know,
iPhone.
And I sent it on the internet
to my office downtown.
They took it.
They turned it into-- a person
down there made a demo from it.
And a few minutes later,
he sent it up by internet.
I had a version of the piece
done within about an hour.
That's the internet for you.
I mean, you can't knock that.
And I said, oh,
here's-- I got the song.
Do you want to give a-- he
said, when did you write it?
I said, while you
were rehearsing,
so I just decided to write it.
[LAUGHTER]
And he said, do you want
to give it to Ed now?
He said, well, yeah, yeah.
We'll give it to-- so
that song ended up--
so the internet's amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, when I
find out-- first
I thought I had to scan things.
Then I realized I could
just take a picture
and send the picture to the--
and someone would put it
into the computer.
And amazing, huh?
So how does it-- I
find it mainly helpful.
It helps me to--
years ago when I
was working on a--
I was working on a,
I think it was "The Hours"
or something like that.
It was a movie.
But it was being
recorded in London.
And the director
called me up-- I
was living in-- I
was in Nova Scotia.
He said, I need some changes.
I need it by tomorrow afternoon.
I said, Scott, you're not going
to get tomorrow afternoon.
He said, yes I will.
I said, what are
you going to do?
He said, someone's flying
to Halifax right now.
They'll be at your
door in six hours.
Do the rewrite.
Give it to him.
He'll get back on the plane.
And I'll have it by
tomorrow afternoon.
And he did.
So that was the old days.
Today, he would just called me
and said, hey send the piece.
And I would send it by internet.
It's amazing, huh?
I was asked, are there any bad--
I guess there are bad things.
But I tend to--
[LAUGHTER]
I tend to look at
the positive stuff.
And you've probably
gathered that already.
I tend to look at the
positive sides of things.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
My name is Rick.
I assume decades ago when
you started composing,
you used paper, pencil,
score sheet, and piano.
As the decades go by,
technology became available.
Have you changed your
process to use software?
PHILIP GLASS: Well, no.
I still use-- now
what I have to do,
the people that make the music
paper don't do it anymore.
But what I found is that their
printers, if you give them
a sample of what you want,
they'll print it for you.
I'm still running
with pencil and paper.
AUDIENCE: You are.
PHILIP GLASS: I am.
And then what I have, I
have some young fellows
that work in the studio for me.
And they put it
into the computer.
Once it gets in the computer,
now anybody can deal with it.
But that the manuscript, no
one can deal with that anymore.
AUDIENCE: Because
I use software.
I use technology devices.
Sometimes I use my
phone for an idea.
And then I go to the
paper, and you know.
I'm wondering iff--
PHILIP GLASS: Well,
you're using both.
I find that, you
know, at this point,
my friends say, well,
why don't you just
learn to write it
into a computer?
And I-- you know, I
say, well, how long will
it take me to really
learn to do it?
They say about six weeks.
And I said, six weeks--
I can write a string
quartet in six weeks.
[LAUGHTER]
I said, well, what would
you rather me do, write
a string quartet or to
learn how-- he said,
no you go write
the string quartet.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
PHILIP GLASS: But,
you know, there's
another thing about the
manuscript, by the way.
I've got-- I don't want to tell
you how many thousands of pages
I've got of manuscript.
If you write music-- and
you have files, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIP GLASS: I can
sell my manuscripts.
You can sell your files.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But I can print
and become files, right?
PHILIP GLASS: Well, OK.
OK, I'll give you that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you so
much for coming, Philip,
and amazing performance
of "Mad Rush."
So Bradley was mentioning
in the beginning of
to talk about how touched he was
yesterday by the performance.
And I was very touched by
your performance as well.
I'm going to
treasure it forever.
I think we all have
these performances
that we get to see-- and
it can be something very
formal like at
Carnegie Hall, or it
can be somebody playing the
guitar in front of you--
that we treasure very much.
And I would like
to ask you, do you
have one or a few
specific things
that you witnessed in
music that you would like
to take with you to eternity?
PHILIP GLASS: There
are two things
I saw that were really amazing.
When I was about 18 or 17
or 18, I was in New York
and Segovia came to
play at Carnegie Hall.
Carnegie Hall is
a pretty big hall.
He sat at the front of
the stage in a chair.
And he's kind of a little guy.
He leaned over with the
guitar-- the place was packed--
and began playing very quietly.
After about a few minutes,
it filled the room.
You could hear
every note he did.
And he sat and just played for
maybe, maybe 75, 80 minutes.
It was a memorable concert.
Then I had another memorable
concert about the same time.
I was at the Village
Vanguard in New York.
And John Coltrane was
playing with a band.
And he was playing insanely
good, beautiful music.
But you know how
a band will come.
They'll come-- it
was break time.
So the band stopped, and
they went to the bar.
John Coltrane just kept playing.
He played straight
through the break.
He was still playing--
he was still playing
the changes in everything.
They came back from the break.
They picked up
their instruments.
And they just started
playing again.
[LAUGHTER]
He never stopped,
I said, oh boy,
that's-- that's a monster--
[LAUGHTER]
PHILIP GLASS: --a
monster talent.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARTURO BEJAR: Thank you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
So you told a
story earlier about
when you were playing
with a musician who
played the gourd harp,
and how the tuning was
very different from your piano
and sort of the consonances
that you're used to, and that
you didn't tune your piano
to adjust to him.
And he adjusted to you.
Have you ever had to
adjust to another tuning
system in a
collaboration and really
had to internalize what
they consider consonances
as we might consider
dissonances?
And if so, what was your
experience with that?
PHILIP GLASS: Well, I haven't.
When I work with people,
mostly the people who
have been-- they
might be Indian,
or from Africa, or maybe from
Australia-- the Australian,
that guy, in order
to change keys,
he had a-- he had another
instrument with him.
He couldn't just cut off part
of it, or he wasn't willing to.
Mostly, it's just the way it is.
I mean, we have all-- they're
over here where we are.
We've got all these
instruments playing.
So for six or eight of
us to change our tuning
and there's one guy
who's out of tune-- well,
he's not really out of tune.
He's playing in his own tuning.
It's easier for him
to change than for us.
And we usually do it that way.
I haven't had to do that.
ARTURO BEJAR: Yeah, but
separate from tuning,
like I thought
when I've heard you
talk about when you first got
exposed to [INAUDIBLE] music.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah.
ARTURO BEJAR: And you
were trying to notate,
and you kept getting it-- they--
PHILIP GLASS: Well,
that's different.
I had problems with
the rhythmic structure.
This wasn't about the tuning.
I could write them.
Because [INAUDIBLE],
he-- I asked him
what he was going to do.
He said, well, I'm going to play
[INAUDIBLE] which is usually
in F sharp.
But I'm going to play it
down half a step enough
for everybody else.
And that's what he did.
So it made it very easy for us.
But I was writing
down the music.
And Alla Rahka, the tabla
player said, no, the accents
are in the wrong
place, the wrong place,
they're in the wrong place.
And I didn't know what he meant.
So I would try and write it
out again in a different way.
And he said, no.
And he says, the
notes are the same.
Well, the notes are the same.
I don't know what the
hell he was talking about.
It was the first
morning of our collab.
You know, I was hired
for that morning.
And I couldn't
afford to get fired.
I was living on a very
small fellowship in Paris.
And I knew I was-- I had
to solve this problem.
And it's nothing like--
it was like, I say,
I think I've got an
execution to focus the mind.
So my execution would
have been if I got fired.
And I looked at the music paper.
And I did an inspiring thing.
I took my eraser, and I
erased all the bar lines.
And I looked at it again.
And I saw a string of notes.
And I looked at it, and now I
saw groups of twos and threes.
I didn't see the
bar lines anymore.
I saw three, three, two, two,
two, three, three, two, two.
And I realized, just
by looking at it.
And I saw that--
I don't know how
I did this very, very quickly.
I saw that the first
four or five notes,
they would add up to 16.
The second was 16.
The third one was 16.
And I saw that there
was a larger group of 16
that all the threes
and twos fit into.
And so I just put
the bar line there.
And I said, what's this?
And he said, oh,
that's called the tal.
And the tal just means the
length, the length of the--
and I found out later
that it could be 14 beats.
It could be 17 beats.
It could be 8 beats.
But the music have to follow
that all the way through.
And then I found
out also later--
I didn't know this at
the time-- that when
they play the first beat,
they call that the som.
Now when the sitar player was
playing with the tabla player,
sometimes they would
be together at the som.
But sometimes they
would purposely
miss the som for
two or three cycles.
And if you were in the audience,
the audience was like this.
They're getting very nervous.
And finally, they
came to the som.
And they go, [SIGH].
[LAUGHTER]
It was the most amazing thing.
This was in China.
It was a madras at the time
when I first saw this happen.
And the whole audience just
went-- when everyone hit.
But so the play of
the music had to do
with the length of the rhythm,
not with the key of the piece.
You know, in Western
music, the tension
is between the tonality and
the-- between the harmony
and the melody.
I'll put it that way.
For traditional rhythmic music,
it's mostly just decorative,
really.
And in Indian music, the
tension was completely
between the rhythm
and the vocal line.
There was no harmony.
But I was really--
thinking back on it,
that probably changed my life,
the fact that I figured that.
I don't even know how I did.
It was just luck
in a certain way.
If I had got--
because after that,
I stayed with Ravi for
the rest of that week.
And I began working with him.
And later on, I
played music with him.
So it became-- it opened up a
whole world of music for me.
Had I missed that moment,
I would've been fired.
And I wouldn't be-- I'll
be teaching counterpoint
in some jerk work conservatory
in Ohio or someplace.
[LAUGHTER]
ARTURO BEJAR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That sounds awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to
figure out how to phrase this.
So you write a piece of music,
people perform it, right?
We have pieces of music.
And that's been going on
for quite a long time.
But there's this
modern phenomenon
of mashing up and
re-mixing, which
seems to be throwing
all of that for a loop.
People write lots of
tiny pits of music.
People perform by--
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do
you think of that?
It seems to be changing--
PHILIP GLASS: I
actually encourage it.
When someone other-- we have
a record that we put out
on our record company
where we had people do
covers of pieces of mine.
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
PHILIP GLASS: They did
exactly what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PHILIP GLASS: They-- and
I said, oh, you know,
I wrote it that way.
But let me hear what someone
else thinks about it.
I was always interested
in what they did.
Now, that's not always true.
I just had a conversation
with a conductor who
was looking at a
new piece of mine
for two pianos and an orchestra.
It's a double piano concerto.
He said, well, I'm going
to the rehearsal tomorrow.
But I have to tell you that I
think the writing is much too
thick for the orchestra.
I said, yeah-- I
said, Dennis, that's
what I'm writing these days.
I'm writing very dense music.
I said, look, if you want to,
just thin it out if you want.
You can play it any
way you want to.
It's not going to bother me.
Of course, when I was
thinking to myself,
I'll just put the music
right back afterwards anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
It wasn't going to change it.
But I said, if it makes you
happy to do it that way,
just go ahead and do it.
And he called me
up the next day.
And he said, well,
we tried it out.
I tried it out with
your orchestration,
and it sounded great.
He said-- it was the first time
this guy had ever said to me--
he said, I was wrong,
and you were right.
He never had said that.
He's been playing music of
mine for 30 years-- first time
he said, no, you were right.
And I said-- I said this before,
maybe yesterday-- what happens
is that you begin to
hear music differently.
Now if I can hear
it differently,
so I hear-- what sounds
right to me sounds different.
I'm not even sure why that is.
The neurologists say that the
brain continues to evolve,
you know?
Or does it devolve?
I don't know.
But I find that I hear--
I'm actually hearing things
differently.
And I'm writing different music.
And I don't know why, except
things sound right to me
that didn't sound
right to me before.
And I write them down.
And I make everyone play
it the way I wrote it.
[LAUGHTER]
And people who know
the music very well
will try to correct it.
And I say-- they
said, this is wrong.
And I said, no, it's not wrong.
Just play the way I wrote it.
But apart from that,
a lot of people
make arrangements, like a
flutist will make arrangements
of a violin concerto,
because there
is no-- they haven't
written a flute concerto.
Or someone will take
a piece for orchestra
and they'll play it with
a smaller orchestra.
And they'll say,
what do you think?
And I say, well, I think,
if you make an arrangement,
I want a copy of it.
And it will belong
to my company.
And we'll rent it out to
other people if it's good.
And if it isn't
good, I won't use it.
Well, I don't really-- the same
thing with dance companies,
and they want to take
a piece of music.
They said, do you want
to see our company dance?
I said, hell no.
Just take the music,
and do the dance.
What am I going to do, tell
them I don't like the dance?
[LAUGHTER]
What do I know about dance?
So I'm actually more interested
in what other people think,
except when it's a
new piece and I'm
worrying-- I'm
working on language,
then I want to hear--
I'm very obsessed right
now with a different
language in my music.
That's happened in the
last two or three years.
I can see that is happening.
And a cellist friend of mine
was playing a [INAUDIBLE]
I wrote for the solo cello.
And I went to hear
the recording.
And it took them
hours to record.
It took him really about an
hour or two just to record it.
I said, what do you think?
I said, Matt, what
do you think of this?
He said, well it's an
amazing piece of music.
I said, yeah, but who the
hell is going to play it?
He said, oh, people
will play it.
He said, they'll learn to
play it, and they'll play it.
And that's probably true.
Now, but is that a good idea?
I don't know.
I don't know the
answer to these things.
In many ways,
I'm-- in many ways,
after the moment of writing,
I'm just another listener.
It depends whether I still
got my composer hat on.
If my composer hat isn't on, I
don't hear it that way anymore.
And I'm very open
to different things.
I rarely tell
people that they've
done it wrong unless they've
actually done it wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Unfortunately--
is this a yes/no question?
AUDIENCE: It's a little--
MALE SPEAKER: If it's a short
question with a short answer,
we can do this.
PHILIP GLASS: The short
answer is the hard part.
Sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: I'm not
going to say that.
But the answer doesn't
depend on me, I guess.
I'm just kind of curious
about the creative process,
your creative
process in general.
[LAUGHTER]
Can I?
MALE SPEAKER: The answer is yes.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So one thing I
find amazing and fascinating
about music is how-- you know,
I've heard analysis of pieces
by Chopin, Beethoven,
where there's
this small motif of three,
four notes that-- you know,
it's gradually generates the
whole entirety of a piece.
And I find it
absolutely incredible
how that process can come
up, how the process works
to come up with
that piece, yet you
have these little repetitive
motifs from beginning to end.
And I wonder, how do you do it?
What your process?
Do you start with the whole?
Do you start with some
melodies, with some small idea?
PHILIP GLASS: It can
be anything, really.
But a lot of it is detail.
I was watching my-- I have
a 14-year-old son that
was drawing a drawing
the other day.
And he was doing the
tiniest little lines.
He just took his time and
just put all the lines
that he wanted to.
And he-- I could
see he was getting
obsessed with some detail.
And that happens in music too.
And now, particularly,
I'll write a piece.
And I'll write music.
And I'll hear it the next--
I'll go back and play it
the next day.
I'll play it on the
piano or look at it.
And I'm not sure I got it right.
The problem is that
I hear it right.
And the biggest problem is, am
I writing down what I heard?
And once I write it down,
I'm not sure anymore.
Because the evidence
of the written music
can be compelling, but
it might not be correct.
And one of the biggest
problems that I have
is, am I writing
down what I hear?
And I'm not sure.
I do my best.
I think everyone has a problem.
I hear-- I listen to the
"Grosse Fuge" of Beethoven.
I'm not sure of
some of those notes.
Maybe he didn't
hear them either.
I don't know.
But you hear that in other
people's music, don't you?
Or are you a musician?
AUDIENCE: I wish.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A very poor one.
PHILIP GLASS: But
you can hear things.
And you say, I wonder
if that-- I don't know.
OK, I'm sorry we
ran out of time.
MALE SPEAKER: No,
this was such a treat.
We really, on behalf
of Google, really
want to thank both of you
for the wisdom you shared,
the performance.
It was really special
and meaningful for us.
Thank you so much.
PHILIP GLASS: Thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[APPLAUSE]